good morning John surprise it's me I'm
here on the channel I thought I was
getting a colonoscopy today but it turns
out that I'm not you'd think that's
something I would know I scheduled one
and then I started a new medicine and
then they wanted to push it back but
then I didn't take it off my schedule so
I have one in May it's fine you don't
need to know but that means I had a
whole extra day which is great because I
have a lot to do put on a presentation
about titles and thumbnails thinking
about redesigning my office I got a
couple of updates I need to send out to
the community here project for awesome
is coming I think I might have like a
mild existential crisis about halfway
through the day I need to get lunch at
some point I might just make a sandwich
first the subscriptions system that we
use to run the awesome socks club and
coffee and also Pizza Miss stuff they
had a weird glitch so it may have sent
you an email that you're gonna get
skipped for this month you won't uh
we're working on a fix uh sorry that
shouldn't happen again as a man once
said still some glitches to work out and
I really am grateful because people are
so understanding when stuff like this
happens so thanks for that I'm so
excited about how well those things have
done we've got you know thousands of
people getting coffee every month and
tens of thousands of people getting
socks every month it makes me think a
lot about what's possible and thinking a
lot about what's possible these days
often requires me to think about what is
impossible which is me doing more stuff
which is a shame because I very much
love to do more stuff I'm sure that's
something no one's ever noticed about me
also the project for awesome is
approaching rapidly February 17th and
video submissions are open we used to do
it everybody would upload the video on
the same day YouTube doesn't really care
about that anymore so you can upload it
beforehand get it into our system and
then we can review the videos and pick
out ones that we might want to feature
during the project for awesome live
stream so if you want to make your
project for awesome video do that and
then submit it at project for
awesome.com if you don't know what I'm
talking about the project for awesome is
a yearly 48-hour live stream that John
and I and friends have been doing since
2007. we raise money we send people
things in exchange for that money both
physical and digital things there's a
whole campaign that will be live during
the live stream during the first half we
raise money for save the children and
Partners in Health and during the second
half we raise money for organizations
voted on by the community and we decide
that by watching videos that people make
talking about the great work that
organizations they care about do in
their community and in the world so if
you want to make a video supporting your
favorite charity you can do that it
doesn't have to be more than a minute
long tell us about the problem that
organization is interfacing with why
it's a big deal and how they're trying
to solve that problem that's that's the
basic format of most YouTube videos
about anything what is the problem why
is it important what should we do about
it that's so much of what humans do and
it's a good format it's a reason why we
do things that way I don't know which of
the things that I do is the most
important one or even which one I enjoy
the most so that's like a weird thing
for a bunch of chemical reactions to
think I'm also going to be doing the
nerdfighteria census fairly soon so if
you haven't filled out the survey
there's a link in the description to do
that so that we can get more data about
how people are feeling about
nerdfighteria it's good to get a broad
base of information from all across this
community so that's in the description
as well and what else is going on
Catherine and I have been having a good
old time with delete this lately we kind
of fell into a new format called wet or
dry where we talk about one wet thing
and one dry thing and then try and
figure out which of the things is better
it sounds like a terrible idea for a
podcast but it's maybe my best idea for
a podcast ever it's very fun and it's
been very silly it maybe is not for kids
though just FYI I mostly mentioned that
so the babies out there know how cool
they are for listening and hydrogen
isn't it interesting that there is an
element where if you take away the
electron it's just a proton it's still
hydrogen that's how it works elements
are defined by the number of protons
they have and hydrogen has one proton so
if there's just one proton it's hydrogen
that's cool I don't know why it takes me
out of the frame a little bit additional
thing to share Hank's Channel got one of
these so that see that's you right there
you see yourself that's you that's what
you look like to me it's not how I think
of you anyway I have no idea which of
the things that I just said is going to
fit in this video definitely not all of
it that's for sure John I'll see you on
Tuesday